coming in from the odd area that wolf is
spinning around like a top out there
trying to find cam bedrosian
the trojan making his first start since
june of 2019. it'll be the eighth start
of his career he should be fresh
he's well rested john
swing of the miss ortega is down on
strikes
one away here in the first inning that's
a good start good splitter here breaking
down and away from ortega probably not
expecting that with a full count
fly ball left center field mccutcheon
and o'double out there mccutcheon's
toward the track makes the catch
and a one two three first inning
well if it is one and done it was a nice
job by cambridge
kyle hendricks on the mound
we've seen it over the years we know
what we're getting it's sink or change
up four seam curve ball
if he's hitting his spots
his changeup's in the right place he's
very very tough to hit
and a swing and a miss struck him out
overloaded him there with change-ups and
gets the first out just goes lower than
low here kind of starts it as we talked
about last couple nights middle of the
play change-ups are very hard for
hitters to lay off of and kyle's just
never gets there he pulls the string as
good as anybody in the game segura
second harper at first kyle looking for
something on the ground at someone
there's a ball on the ground at someone
alcantara
duffy onto schwendell and they turn it
that was exactly what hendricks was
looking for that'll work yeah
here's wilson contreras
swig and a miss
the splitter has helped him get a couple
strikeouts against the first four
hitters so what a way here in the second
continue to throw it the same aggression
he throws that good fastball see the
tumbling action that's good look at that
grip too yeah
and that one misses and wisdom is a
board here comes joe girardi and that's
it so bedrosian's down it's an ending in
the third and they'll go to the lefty
matt moore
that one's over to third galvez to
second for juan segura to first in time
one pitch away that's right five four
three double play
so after moore walks out contrary to
lead off the inning moore walks ortega
hammer comes in and walks schwendell and
the bases are loaded and here comes ian
half
that one in the dirt and it hit him and
that'll force in the first run of the
game in to score alcantara a base is
loaded hit by pitch one nothing comes
and here's contreras struck out his
first time
that's drilled to the center that's a
base hit or take in to score they'll
hold schwendell as the throw comes in
and it's two nothing rbi single for
wilson contreras and that was a bullet
so here's wisdom who accepted a walk in
the second
figure four leg lock that one down to
the left center and that'll touch down
for a hit in to score schwindel taps on
his heels into second his wisdom
and the cubs now have a four nothing
lead
and matt duffy will be the ninth man to
bat in the inning
that's drilled to left field going back
mccutchen looking out of here oh that
followed a chance and it got out and
matt duffy
his fifth of the year
and it's now seven nothing middle in
heater just throws his hands at the ball
barrels it up again matt duffy
is crushing the ball in september he's
been hitting it hard he's been hitting
over the fence in the gap and it
continues again this evening and the
phillies are down seven to nothing and
bryce harper will lead things off
harper the other way going back out of
his hat back toward the wall he jumps
it's off the top of the wall
and it's in play he didn't know where it
was
half that is harper's at second that's
his 35th double of the year he's now
hitting 12 straight
now the second base umpire's saying it's
a home run i don't think it is i think
it hit the top of the fence
yeah that's not a home run nope it
didn't go over the metal did it it did
not emily bryce is going to put the
homer had on just yet and that was close
well it'll extend his hitting streak to
12 straight yeah they're putting him
back to second
gt is hit by the pitch that puts two on
pedigree has popped
ground ball right side see there again
it goes past window hendricks is there
covering that same thing happened last
night
exactly why you backed your partner over
there and that took a bad hop that's a
really bad hop so second and third and
one out here's andrew mccutchen one two
pitch
opposite way for mccutchen going back
out at his revos it's over his head at
one hop off the wall two runs will score
mccutchen goes to second two run double
it's a seven two game
yeah he thought it may have been higher
maybe taking the over off the end of the
bat that's nice
sprinkle over to shortstop it's an
infield hit to put runners at first and
third
[Applause]
and it hits him that'll load the bases
up
freddie just said something to matt
joyce as he went up the first base line
three balls two strikes one out
low ball four that'll force it around
it's a seven three game and the tying
run is coming to the plate and it's so
doable that's coming up he's over two
yeah if he throws a change up you get
out in front you still keep it there
there you go broken back live drive into
left field a runner score galvez at
third it's a 7-4 game the bases remain
loaded
like a merry-go-round huh yeah keep it
going segora is one for two
broken bat looper out towards short it's
gonna drop and it's off the glove of
alcantara
they've got one at second oh man oh he
was a he was able to get in
a run scores at seven five
gonna be awfully careful with harper
here 3-0
ball four he walks him
that'll load the bases up again
jt is due up
broken bat loafer back toward the middle
of base hit one red is in here comes
segora heading home and the phillies
have tied the game
seven run fourth inning you can go
dancing all through the stands
harper hit a bullet off of rodriguez the
first night in here tuesday night
[Applause]
shot the other way it is a fair ball
down the left-field line herrera's
heading home the phillies have taken the
lead it's an rbi double by harper his
second double of the game it's eight to
seven
this wacky wonderful game of baseball
the phillies were down seven runs and
now they lead it eight to seven i want
to talk about a guy that is due for a
big extra base hit it's glorious
just a hit
and a lot of driving to left field
there's a hit two runs are going to
score the throw to the plate is up going
to second is d.d two rbis for gregorius
the phillies lead it 10-7 runaway in the
batter now is wilson contreras
contreras crushes one center field way
back and into the forest and gone
wilson contreras with an absolute bomb
number 19
and the cubs get a run back and it's now
10 8. that was swatted and freddie's
forward deerlings coming in
back toward the middle another base hit
and
it's two for two that's all he does is
hit top on his birthday oh yeah
has an rbi single tonight he's also
reached on an error and scored a run
lines one to left field that's going to
be in for a base hit it's going to go to
the corner galva scores beerly is
speeding around third heading for home
he's gonna score it's a two-run double
the phillies leading 12 to eight
bryce harper
with runners at first and third
and that one
steep right field forget about it gone
into the second deck
three run home run
he has lifted the lead off the ballpark
just incredible what this man has done
in the second half
climb on boys
i got some broad shoulders
[Applause]
[Music]
all four o'duba walks
that'll load the bases up for gene
segura two pitch coming
there's a base in it to center field
gene keeps it rolling
mccutchen scores
veerling scores
two run hit for segora the hitch just
keep on coming 17-8
on ball with one strike to wisdom
bouncer to third teres has got it across
the diamond phillies win
17-8
they take the series against the cubs
yeah if you turned it on in the third
i don't think you thought you'd hear the
words phillies win
when this one was all said and done but
they did
in what is a remarkable victory